tell stories that stick you know trust
that you have an interesting story
it might just be covered up with cobwebs
of of data and and dust of uh of kind of
uninteresting factual jargony things
take those away
kind of sand off the the layers of paint
that somebody has covered up your story
with over the years and get it then to a
beautiful Sheen
you know polish it let it shine and and
really put it out there and then tell it
with passion welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
[Music]
thank you for being here
second time I'm so excited it's been a
while last time it was during the height
of kovid good God
exactly so it's the second time but
three years different so uh so it's I
feel like it's a it's a brand new story
and it certainly is a brand new story
today we're talking about sticking to my
story it's your new book and I believe
that I'm catching you on launch day
only for you Michael only for you I love
it well I can't wait to read the book
myself and um and it sounds like you
know you shared with me a little bit
about about what's inside and I'm
excited to dive into it over these 20
minutes and and get some some bits and
bites and stories for what to expect but
uh you know one one of the things you
mentioned is that Tim Draper rode the
forward which is incredible so
incredible guy and so I already know
that it's going to be a big hit and tell
me a little bit about what led you to
write the book and uh and you know you
have such a significant experience with
storytelling and Pitch decks and working
with entrepreneurs and so tell me all
about it
so I mean for years I've known that I've
had the book inside and and it needed to
be written and I've had people say oh
you should write a book and it's like
yeah yeah one of those days you'll get
around to it and then some sometimes one
of those days just kind of happened and
the right signal happens and my
publisher Vince I actually was
interviewed about a little over a year
ago on his podcast uh chasing the
insights and we really hit it off and
it's just like mentioning offhand that
he had a book publishing company and I'm
like
come again and I really love his
methodology because it's really hand
holding the author through the process
leading through the concept the
structure the outline I had an
accountability call with him every week
on the calendar which kept me writing it
kept it real and I started writing last
May and in October
um 2022 2022 six months ago that's
pretty quick right yeah I mean it was
literally like I wish I could have found
the USB port on my brain and gone
because it was so ready to come out
um and it's funny because over the years
I've written a lot of content for
startups and and
um I always like oh this will make a
good chapter for my book one day
so I had a lot of content kind of ready
it just needed to be edited and and put
together for the book well so it the
fact that you had a lot of content ready
for the book is because obviously you've
been generating a lot of value and uh
and uh with a lot of insights over over
the years so tell me a little bit about
uh you know what you know the different
things that you've experienced that have
led you to being able to write sticking
to my story
have been so lucky Michael to work in my
ikigai as as the Japanese call it my
reason for being which is you know where
you can do good for the world and give
them something they need something
you're good at something you love doing
and something you can get paid for I
mean that's winning the lottery every
single day
um so I work with startups and
organizations
um helping them craft and deliver
powerful messages that drive to business
results
um 2008 was a pivotal year for me we're
kind of in a sort of Shadow time of that
uh era um when I started working with
startups mainly and
um seeing how the need over the past
well more than a decade has just
increased to be important how we're
again in a financial crisis and a lot of
Uncertain times and your story matters
more than ever
and it people are asking me is this the
time to fundraise should I be
fundraising what's going on in the
market and and what investors are
telling me is it's about bringing value
immediate value and it's also about
being able to convey the story of what
it is that you're going to do and why it
matters why it's relevant these days
and why is storytelling so hard
it's hard because
um it's like when it's your own story
either one of two things usually happens
either people are like
I don't know how to talk about myself or
they're like oh my God yes so our
product is the best an assist and they
go on and on and on and on and it's like
okay shut up I got it but I didn't get
it so the biggest mistake people make is
starting from them you need to do the
180 and start from them the other side
and that's what the power of
Storytelling does because you're telling
a story that shows that you understand
the pain and the need of your audience
and they are listening and going
yeah that's right that happened to me
that happened so when I know I get it
they're nodding they're with you and
that's creating that power of influence
because they are agreeing with you and
these stories that stick and the title
is very intentional I remember pitches
that I heard 10 12 15 years ago because
the stories were so powerful and I give
some of those examples in the book like
eat which story and cure-like story and
the Tokyo story you know some of those
are in there and I just treasure these
because I mean I I'll work on a lot of
pitches and I still remember the great
stories
interesting can you sort of just distill
what was it what you know if you look at
these stories that you remember what
really does it what is the impact that
they leave on you and where does that
come from why do you still remember
those stories from all those years ago
so I write about it in the book like why
storytelling is so impactful and our
brains are really hardwired for stories
um you don't have kids yet but with my
kids they they are story fiends and and
I love telling them stories and I love
hearing stories I took them to see a
production of uh Sound of Music last
night and I cried the whole beginning
because there's something so powerful
about sharing a story and sharing
something that so because because I
guess to me having watched it as a child
with my brother and sister and now
taking my daughters to see it and the
music and the story behind it is so
powerful that I was just sitting there
weeping
that is what stories do for us it holds
tons of feeling and emotion and other
moments that get on lot that unlock
feelings and that is the best sales
technique anywhere like Maya Angelou
said people don't remember what you say
they remember what you made them feel
I'm paraphrasing but that's exactly it
incredible okay so take me back just a
bit before we look back to sticking to
my story your love for for storytelling
where does that emerge from
wow that's a good question I don't think
anyone has asked me yet
um I I remember in fourth grade
discovering Nancy Drew and falling in
love with reading and I would like walk
around with sacks full of books so I I
was an Avid Reader as a child but we
still actually read books and not just
articles and posts
um and my daughters now are are huge
readers which I love and then I always
said about myself I'm not a writer it's
funny I didn't think of myself as a
writer but then I found myself writing
other people's stories and loving it and
seeing all the pieces come together oh
they are saying this they're saying this
they're saying that how could we weave
it together in this beautiful tapestry
and I became addicted to that and I love
hearing stories I love hearing people's
stories so it's just been this thing
that's evolved personally and then
professionally and then understanding
the anatomy of a good story and how it
can help and my hope is with this book
that it'll be helpful to people all over
the world
um that that you know want to tell
better stories that want to write better
messages
so when you go out and envision writing
this book so I want to take you back I
guess to last May right and yeah and it
started before that but I wanted to get
back to last May and you're imagining to
yourself you know what a person may
enter the book you know what mindset a
person may enter the book with and what
mindset they may leave with at the end
of it sort of the impact that this book
is going to make on them what is your
vision what is what is sort of the the
energy that you're bringing with you
into into this process the transition
that you hope people would make as a
result of reading it
I like to drink my own champagne that
sounds better than eating my own dog
food so I wanted it to be very
storytelling
so so I was very Frank it's very much my
voice it's funny when when Vince's
editors were working on it he had to
keep telling them no don't change that
that's her boy
because it's like it's not always proper
and Prince so for me it was much more
important for it to be accessible to
people for them to go oh yeah I know oh
I get that oh I can I can make that work
so really breaking down the bits to
empower people to tell great stories to
write great investor pitches sales
pitches it's earmarked as the Alchemy of
Storytelling for startups
at first I was going to write it for
like everyone it just would have been
way too long so we started with startups
but there's a lot in there that is
relevant to anyone in any business
so how so how would a person not
pitching a startup you know how would
this be relevant for them you know
storytelling in the book specifically
first of all understanding the power of
Storytelling what it is it's not just
telling random little anecdotes it's
tying it all together it's sticking an
anchor in people's brains and just the
full the psychology and the philosophy
behind what the other side is responding
to what you're saying getting out of
your own headspace and turning it around
flipping it and looking at the other
side that to me is key Henry Ford said
the real secret to success is being able
to see your point of view and someone
else's at the same time and sometimes I
mean we get so caught up in our own that
it's very hard to acknowledge the other
side and when they don't feel
acknowledged in her they ain't gonna buy
from you they ain't gonna invest in you
they're not gonna want to be around you
they're just going to feel intimidated
you want to kind of create that power
yeah and so biggest pitfalls that that
we may make in our daily life while
storytelling or trying to engage with
somebody take anything your partner your
kid you have kids your your
workmates if you are constantly talking
to them in a way that makes them feel
you know that you are the one bringing
down the word rather than getting into
their position looking at the world
through their eyes using the empathy and
the understanding and and kind of
speaking in a way that's much more I get
you I'm feeling the pain
um I've seen this happen and here's what
we can do together to to work on this so
so storytelling is really about I have a
four chunk or four Act
uh structure for it that I lay out in
the book I mean I I'm a theater uh baby
and I've always acted and I've been
going to Broadway shows ever since I was
like four or five and there's a real
intentional act building in there and we
always are going to start off with the
pain
they're no Superman emerges until we
have the Lex luthors of the world that
kind of come up and and oh my gosh that
just happened what do we do now the the
heroes are only as good as the villains
are
the heroes are only as good as the
villains are I love it okay so so I'm an
early stage entrepreneur
and um and I'm storytelling every day
right I'm pitching every day all day to
myself to my mom to my employees to my
investors probably your dad more than
your mom I'd assume my dad as well my
mom is quite is quite a she's quite
critical and and very very smart but
um but certainly to my dad as well of
course but you know what what do I
really need what can I do so so taking
it in a step back and saying okay I'm
not a Storyteller not a storyteller
born a Storyteller and or I'm guessing
this is an acquired skill and and I
think that what you do is you not only
help formulate this story but you also
help entrepreneurs learn how to think
about storytelling yeah and I got that
from you and a lot of different
conversations that we've had so
what what is sort of the process that I
can go through or can aim to go through
as an entrepreneur here
so um first of all some people are born
storytellers I mean we all are born
storytellers we all are born story
listeners some of us lose it over the
years like kids are great storytellers
yeah that's true okay you can call it in
too great a detail you know I have to
always stop myself and and like be
patient with my girls telling every
single detail of what happened at school
because I want them to tell me things
and as they get older I can also help
them shape it
um but some people are born better
storytellers some people have the
Charisma and the the wow factor like an
Obama or a Clinton or a Gandhi or a
Martin Luther King someone that you just
listen to and you're like now Steve Jobs
for example he's one of the best
storytellers of our era but for sure
when he started out he wasn't really a
book called becoming Steve Jobs where it
talks about his journey in his
Relentless reversal of everything being
just right so there is a method to
telling a story
and then to practicing it so you become
better at telling it but people often
come to me they're like no no I don't
need to work on the content people say
I'm not very interesting I'm not very
engaging and I say here's the thing once
your content is great your story is
great 50 of nerves or not being a great
presenter are gone because you're not
grabbing and trying to figure out what
you're doing you're fully focused you're
telling a story that is you it's the DNA
of you
brought into the story
problems icing it really does yeah but
you mentioned something interesting
earlier about disconnecting so doing
this 180 and instead of focusing on on
you you're putting you're focusing on
them who's listening tell me more about
that let's speak a little bit more about
you know putting ourselves outside of
the equation and and listening for what
the other side may be hearing absolutely
so there we actually take in information
through three channels our visual our
auditory and our kinesthetic and we we
also
um communicate to different levels of
people's understanding obviously the
brain top of Mind questions but the
heart and the gut also are listening and
taking in the information so this whole
pipeline right here has to be taken in
and how do you touch people's heart and
gut Beyond just their mind which is
working furiously trying to understand
what you're doing you think about their
pain their need or if it's an investor
the need or the pain of the audience
that you're going to be addressing not
all investors are going to use your
product they're not developers they're
not yeah
um and then at the same time
you're thinking about that and you're
starting your story off with that you
are answering a line of questions you're
intuiting their questions what they're
going to ask now people are like but how
do I know what they're going to ask you
know
I have a list in the book of over a
hundred questions that investors ask and
some tips on how to answer them so you
can be ready and no okay and now my
whole framework is built around
questions that they would ask the
investor questions the who's the what's
the where's the whys what's why are you
different how is this um going to make
money
um how does it work or do you have IP
protection so by already answering the
questions before they even ask it you're
relaxing their brains and you're taking
them on a journey because there's a very
intentional order to how their questions
go
it doesn't start from here it starts
from here
with the pain the empathy then go to the
the the the the you know what it is that
you're gonna do so you're the star of
the show but you've kind of brought in
in a way where you started off with The
Gap and now how You're Gonna Fill that
Gap
what are ways in which I can find the
holes in my story so whatever story I
tell there's going to be holes and
iterations on exactly you cannot hear
your own holes you have to then tell the
story you've created to your team your
partners your your family your Uber
driver your you know whatever you have
an opportunity and get their feedback
now you at some point you're gonna stop
getting feedback because I mean with
with my clients we have a two-hour
session and they walk out with a fully
scripted deck and I tell them listen
you're going to hear a lot of notes and
a lot of people tell you this isn't
there this shouldn't be there this you
can't change your message every time
somebody makes a note you have to trust
that that once you're feeling that don't
create what I call a patchwork pitch
where you're just like patching in if
somebody says something with meaning
great make a slide you can also put it
in backup so if anybody asks it it's
ready but don't bloat your deck with all
of these insights trust yourself
but practice practice practice practice
100 and so um Donna before we leave
um 20 minutes ago by way too quickly if
there's one thing that you'd like
readers to be left with
from your book oh wow there's so many
things
um
tell stories that stick you know trust
that you have an interesting story
it might just be covered up with cobwebs
of of data and and dust of uh of kind of
uninteresting factual jargony things
take those away
kind of sand off the the layers of paint
that somebody has covered up your story
with over the years and get it then to a
beautiful Sheen
you know polish it let it shine and and
really put it out there and then tell it
with passion
because it's yours it's your story in
the minute we've created it from and I'm
when I write stories with my when I
write decks with my clients I don't use
my words I kind of Channel it I'm
basically Donna GPT everybody's going
GPT crazy I've been doing this for 20
years ingesting mountains of data and
spitting up beautiful messages
everything's going oh that's so cool I'm
like um whatever
I've been doing that
um and actually my last chapter it's
called the future of Storytelling and as
I was writing the book Chachi Pizza
Jasper all these tools were coming out
and I asked them what they had to say
about it
read the book you'll know people are
like oh wow aren't you going to be out
of business that a Tome where they
called just got just raised a huge round
and they create storytelling and Pitch
decks and I'm like that's great
I still think I have a job for a while
I'm thinking in a weird place yet but
these tools are great
um assistance for us and expect them to
carry the load they lock the empathy
that's what we're talking about that's
the part they don't know how to connect
the dots yet from yet all right Anna
thank you so much I really really
appreciate the time best of luck with
the launch I can't wait to read the book
myself and uh thank you again for being
on the show and I look forward to having
you again in three years of course oh my
goodness
and by the way if anybody wants to get
it um it's on Amazon Kindle and
paperback
um the audiobook goes into production uh
next week I'm recording it uh and uh
also sticking to my story.com is the
website Donna griffith.com so please
check it out thank you Donna
[Music]